hey what's up everybody it's Warren
and ever since the spider-man far from
home trailer came out yesterday
everybody is wondering when does this
take place does it take place before the
events of Avengers infinity war does it
take place after the events of Avengers
4 or could it possibly happen in between
a lot of people are speculating and
thinking that this is actually a prequel
to Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame but it's not the producers
actually confirmed last year when
spider-man far from home takes place
Kevin Feige who is the president of
Marvel Studios for those of you who
don't know has confirmed himself that
spider-man far from home takes place
right after the events of Avengers
endgame Feige said that spider-man far
from home would be Peter in the rest of
the world trying to return back to
normal life after the events of both
Avengers movies here's what he had to
say in an interview last April with IGN
what is it like to try to go back to a
normal life after what happens in this
movie speaking about Avengers infinity
war then he adds not to mention what
happens in the next Avengers movie
speaking about Avengers and game he
continues to say it's fun to see that
because he can represent you know the
world as a whole as they try to move
forward and you can do it in a way that
is totally unique and totally different
than certainly the two Avengers films
that people are about to see and back in
2017 Amy Pascal who produced spider-man
homecoming spider-man into the
spider-verse and spider-man far from
home said in an interview with fandom
what I think we should focus on is this
Spider Man who started in civil war and
then has this movie and then will be in
The Avengers movie and we are starting
now the next one which will start a few
minutes after Avengers 4 wraps as a
story so there you have it from Kevin
Feige president of Marvel Studios and
producer Amy Pascal who produced fighter
Man far from home
they have both confirmed that spider-man
far from home takes place after the
events of Avengers endgame so that's
confirmed but let me know how you think
everything goes back to normal after the
events of Avengers in game let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and just a reminder of my new Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway still continues if you
would like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]